yeah i mean look at wascarinola is going
to have to be on his a game because you
saw the lineup guys that can do some
damage and honestly chip a big start for
wascar tonight this is you're probably
guy that's going to start game four of
the playoffs for you he needs a good one
and he strikes him out inside corner
paint job from inoah his night off to a
good start no balls two strikes
and
lindor went around back-to-back
strikeouts for noah two up two down
so an important start for wascar you
know who the first three are will he be
the fourth
well a pitching performance like this
would lead you to believe the answer to
that could be yes 12 pitches three
strikeouts in a perfect one two three
first inning final start of the year for
the rookie tyler mcgill he's gonna have
to shore up left-handed hitters hitting
325 right-handed hitters just barely
over 200.
and he strikes out peterson on three
fastballs it's gonna be that kind of
night what's your cue keith do they hang
like a a red uh cape in front of you as
mcgill goes upstairs to strikeout
adrianza so that's five batters in this
game and five strikeouts
definitely
and uh
one two three three strikeout inning for
tyler mcgill
matching huascarnoa
that's not
easy popped up by kevin pillar riley
long run and like freddie freeman makes
a nice play perfect
he's going to go in and tell freddie you
know that play is not that tough
put him at third put him in first
doesn't matter he's continuing to make
great plays defensively one down here in
the third inning
brandon nemo would be next mcgill drives
one out to left center field back in the
gap goes her radio he won't get there
and it hops up against the wall
mcgill heads for second and he is
standing with a well-struck double third
double of the year for mcgill and
that'll push his batting average up over
the mendoza line
[Music]
i mean he hit that like uh yeah sure big
hitter start off the wall here
he's over one with a strikeout pitch on
the way he's over two with two
strikeouts
swings over the top of a slider then
strikeout number four for watchtower
to center field his first time up lindor
at first
and that's drilled into left field and
alonzo's got a second hit this one will
go to the corner lindor racing for third
played by rosario lindor heading home
the relay throw to the plate not in time
and lonzo is going to break for third
the throw by contreras and alonso's out
at third base
nice retrieval by contreras chasing that
ball up the third base line but it's an
rbi double for alonso to give the mets a
one-nothing lead but the catcher here
makes an extraordinary play contreras he
blocks it first
now watch that's a heck of a play right
there folks
was he out though i'm not sure he was
out he was safe but uh this is game
number 160. that's our mets are
challenging
yeah he definitely got his hand in it
that's when you keep the tag on him the
question is did alonzo's hand get the
bag and
it's safe
so there you go
just never know nowadays you don't know
rbi double for pete
there's one looped into the left field
that's going to drop in for a base hit
in front of rosario alonso will score
it's an rbi single for james mccann and
the vets have a two nothing lead big two
out hit for james mccann
the mets have badly lacked two out rbis
this year and hits with runners in
scoring position they've been the worst
in the majors since the all-star break
in that category mccann reaching out on
a pitch that was low and away just off
the end of his bat and he floated that
ball to left center to drive in alonzo
and give the mets a two-nothing lead
and rosario yanks one on the ground
beautiful play alonzo and mcgill gets
over to cover
alonzo making a big play every night
three balls in one strike the pitch
nimmo to drive toward right that's
pretty deep back forward peterson
looking up and it's gone
home run brandon nimmo
he swats a line drive deep into right
field he gets it up near the top house
out there and right and nimo with his
seventh home run of the year gives the
mets a three-nothing lead
nimmo did not look very good in his
first two at bats both strikeouts that
time he just turned on a ball and ripped
it into the seats and right so now it's
pilar facing webb for the first time
since he got hit in the face back in may
a nod by pilar to webb that's before
they started the ab same back that's
great that's great
and pilar strikes out on a change up in
the dirt
as he hopes to be part of a
resurgent mets rotation
as the runner breaks between first and
second bad throw ozzy scooped it up
riley's gonna apply the tag nicely done
mccann got a head start webb stepped off
braves pick him off there's the second
out man you talk about being able to
escape
big strikeout and then you get
that out now
you're one pitch away from getting out
of this thing without any runs at all
good play by albies to run the runner
back and keep an eye on that man maybe
thinking about coming home from third
columbia's the youngest second baseman
in big league history with 30 homers and
100 rbis
the 3-2 pitch
lined in a right center field it's an
rbi hit for ozzie
he's thinking about two throw to second
is gonna be late
hustle double for all bees 39 two base
hits 105 rbis and the braves are on the
board does it again two strike hit we
saw the braves absolutely wear out the
phillies
with two strike hits
mountain keeps it going landon nimo will
step in homer is last time up nemo gets
a breaking ball lifts it to right field
pretty deep back goes peterson near the
wall and it's out of here wow nemo with
his second of the night
a line drive in the fifth inning this
time a towering fly ball as he got a
slider and hit it out of the ballpark
nimmo with a two homerun at night he's
got eight for the year and it's four to
one new york
1-1 pitch there's a high deep drive to
the chop house this is fading way off
into the night that is way out of here
rosario blasts one almost into the
battery
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now a 4-2 ball game as eddie
touches them all for the 14th time this
season
one up one down for adrianza who's one
for three
swaying out a drive
adrianza's hit along horner
they just don't quit
in that line even in a game that you
clutched last night
slowly creeping back in this from this
ball
he hit it
three and two to darno jack peterson
would be next and darno goes down
swinging and the ball game is over
you